from TV shows to movies to Broadway and
then back again
no but seriously is there anything dove
Cameron can't do the talented celebrity
has been blowing up the scene since she
was 16 years old and it's about time we
iron out all the details watch until the
end to find out which popular TV series
dove would love to work on now let's
watch the one and only dove Cameron grow
up before our eyes a star is born in
Seattle dove Cameron isn't your everyday
apperture girl but that's never gone to
her head she was born in Seattle on
January 15 1996 and quickly started
showing signs of stardom by the time she
was eight years old she was already
acting in a community theater at
Bainbridge Performing Arts which is a
pretty big deal according to the actress
being left to her own devices helped her
realize what she wanted out of life from
an early age so during an interview with
Good Day LA this is what dove had to say
I think if you leave a child like - into
their own devices I think that they are
gonna be attracted to what they are but
the actors did point out that being
herself came at a price like most
children dove was bullied by her peers
but she never let it affect her
self-esteem during the same interview
which was posted on YouTube by the dove
Cameron Brasil channel dove explained
why she never let bullying bring her
down this is the advice yes to give to
individuals who might be going through
the same thing like when somebody is
reaching out to you to try and bring you
down it's always a reflection of how
much pain they're in despite going
through what she did Dov learned from
her experience and chooses to encourage
others to do the same now if that isn't
star quality we don't know what is being
of artistic nature might have made her a
target for bullying but even at eight
years old to have knew that following
her passions would pay off in the long
run moving to LA by the time she was 11
years old
dove had already performed on countless
stages in 2007 she landed the role of
Cosette on lei Missouri habla production
shortly after she scored the lead role
of Mary in The Secret Garden
both these productions were hosted by
the Bainbridge Performing Arts School
which helped her realize how much she
enjoyed being on stage
when she was 14 years old dove and her
family moved to Los Angeles and although
this allowed her to spread her wings
even more the move wasn't an easy one
that same year she joined her high
school's national championship show
choir where she showed off her
impressive vocals
despite practically living on stage at
this point dove confessed how she really
feels about performing live while on
talk-show live with Kelly and Ryan this
is what the star had to say I get really
I still get really shy when things are
live I panic as though I've never done
it before it ended up being really
addictive and now all I want to do is
fly theater so basically what was once
doves worst fear ended up becoming her
greatest joy moving to LA allowed dove
to enter a new audition pool which
helped her land some of her first TV and
movie roles despite being an
extraordinarily talented and successful
performer dove still gets the jitters
before auditioning or performing during
the same interview which was posted on
youtube by the celebrity interviews
inside channel dove explained why nerves
can be used as ammo that's what I would
like to believe yeah I mean you know as
performers definitely kicked in so there
you have it guys if something gives you
butterflies it might just be good for
you she's far from shameless we're so
used to dove playing innocence
characters that we forget that she has a
dark side in 2012 Dove landed her first
TV role ever and believe it or not but
it was on the show shameless this TV
series is notorious for hosting some of
the most despicable characters ever
created so imagine our big surprise when
the vanilla star owned up to her part
having a gig on shameless help Duff's
portfolio stand out against other
children her age which ended up being
very useful moving to LA proved to be
the best thing she could have ever done
for her career and she has her mother to
thank for it so how did the star
convince her mom to get to LA this is
what dove had to say while on set of
Kelly and Michael I begged my mother and
me I basically did everything except
make a PowerPoint presentation once la
bound dove managed to land small roles
on TV productions like The Mentalist and
bits and pieces her success came all but
one year after her father passed away
which proved to be the most challenging
period in her life
but as most great artists do she
channeled her emotions into her work and
came up kicking the girl and the
dreamcatcher Dov met her ex-fiance Rian
McCartan while on the set of Liv and
Maddie but before we get into how she
landed this breakthrough role we're
going to focus on her music career it's
no secret that dub is a musical genius
which is why creating her own music came
naturally to her though once upon a time
lovers wanted to invent their own sound
so they created the band the girl and
the dreamcatcher in 2014 but the idea of
releasing their very own EP never
crossed their minds until millions of
fans started asking for more tracks
Daffy came clean about how she and Ryan
created their EP album negatives but a
lot of the songs on the EP we wrote not
thinking they were gonna end up on an EP
and it just again happened very
naturally so in other words dub and Ryan
let their creative juices flow never
once expecting that their music would be
so well received with the help of their
producer Dustin dove and Ryan were able
to finalize their tracks
despite being engaged for six months at
the time dub called off her engagement
with Ryan in 2016 and ultimately pulled
the plug on the girl in the dreamcatcher
but luckily for us
doves singing career is far from over
stay tuned to find out what she's
working on at the moment how she became
a Disney star in 2012 doubled for a part
in the Disney show bitten pieces she
landed the role of Alana and was
introduced to the Disney headquarters
but before the TV series could air the
cast was made to film a pilot episode to
make sure that the series would be well
received Disney allowed a group of kids
to watch the pilot behind the scenes
afterward the kids told the producers
what they liked about the show and what
they didn't according to dub it took
about nine months for Disney to get back
to her but instead of going through with
bits and pieces they offered her her
very own show but before allowing her to
celebrate they threw her a curveball by
stating that she would be playing twins
playing to different characters was
definitely a challenge and this is what
dove had to say about it while on live
with Kelly and Michael basically not but
it's all
twice the fun and I think it really
trains me it's obvious that dove is
quick on her feet
but according to her finding out that
she was going to be starring on Liv and
Maddie came as a shock for the
processing of like what they liked and
what they didn't and it came back and
they're like so your show got picked up
also you're gonna be playing twins so
we'll see you Monday Liv and Maddie came
out on the Disney Channel back in 2013
and came to an end in 2017 so for four
long years dove played two very
different characters during this time
she landed roles in other Disney shows
like the lodge cloud9
and Austin and Ally and before long she
became the renowned Disney star we all
know and love becoming now dove is a
triple threat meaning that she can sing
dance and act this makes her the perfect
Disney star which led her to land the
role of now in The Descendants franchise
despite her cute and innocent looks dog
took on the role of a villain and the
hilarious actress had this to say when
talk-show host Michael asked her about
her character and whether or not he
should be afraid of her should I be
afraid I mean like yeah just about as
intimidating as I am right now
[Music]
the hilarious actors spent hours
learning her lines practicing her music
and memorizing her dance moves she's
dedicated to her role to say the least
and fans are super excited to see what
descendants 3 has in store for them
during an interview that was hosted by
Disney Channel UK Duff came clean about
how she viewed her character mouth and
this is what she had to say complex
firey and sensitive despite being very
different from her on-screen character
Duff can't help but feel connected to
her purple hair and all I'm intense I'm
very intense I'm very complex and very
emotional layered so there you have it
now land of might be worlds of parts but
they still manage to see eye to eye
hairspray live by now it's no secret
that dub enjoys performing live even
though it gives her the butterflies
every once in a while in 2016 Duff
scored the role of amber Von Tussle on
the highly anticipated TV movie
hairspray Live 2016 proved to be a very
active year for the celebrity despite
having committed to Disney productions
like Liv and Maddie and descendants the
star somehow managed to juggle another
project due to her hectic lifestyle Duff
arrived to the hairspray live production
a few weeks late and here's what the
actors had to say about the production
super infectious energy in the same way
that the show is and so it's all it's
got a great marriage to it
despite being way behind on the filming
schedule Duff managed to catch up to the
rest of the cast and delivered a stellar
performance Liv and Maddie dove isn't
one to take all the credit
which is why she's such a beloved
celebrity not only does she enjoy
speaking with her fans and encouraging
others to stand up for themselves but
she also loves giving others credit when
credit is due when Liv and Maddie first
aired many fans believe the characters
to be two entirely different people and
they were shocked to find out that both
Liv and Maddie were played by the same
actress so how did the star managed to
pull this camera trick off well we're
about to find out and they watch my
performance and then they sort of mimic
exactly what I do and they're incredibly
talented being the friendly star that
she is Doug befriended her to body
doubles and still keeps contact with
today after playing Liv and Maddie for a
total of four years Doug decided that it
was time to move on to bigger and better
things for now she's still very
committed to a string of Disney projects
but the actress hinted that she might be
changing directions sometime in the near
future
you can't go without a date Diggy's in
tundrabania and it's not like I'm gonna
go with anyone else at our school moving
away from Disney being a Disney star is
a huge accomplishment one that many
actors wish they could have on their
portfolio dove has never taken her
opportunities for granted which is why
she's stuck by Disney's side for so long
she might have been hailed as the Disney
Channel Queen but that won't stop her
from spreading her wings and seeking New
Horizons
at 22 years old it's only normal for the
actress to want to try out new endeavors
which is why she's confirmed that she'll
be putting Disney in the past once
descendants 3 is finished filming during
an interview with AOL Duff came clean
about her love for Broadway in fact she
stated that pursuing a Broadway career
would be something of great interest for
her this interview is posted on the
build series YouTube channel and it
showcased some pretty compelling
information what would be your dream
role my dream role Elsa no no I think on
on Broadway I really want to play on in
the frozen Broadway incarnation I would
die for that despite having her feet
firmly planted in Los Angeles DA has
been hinting to moving to New York to
follow her passions in the end it's
pretty obvious that dove has what it
takes to make it big on Broadway would
you guys like to see Duff playing Anna
unfrozen the musical because we sure
would watch until the end to find out
which TV show dove is desperately trying
to become a part of her debut single
music has always been in doves blood
which is why she's tried to release a
few singles in the past while herb and
the girl in the dreamcatcher might have
fallen through she never gave up on her
dreams of becoming a famous singer now
that she's completed the filming for
descendants three dub is determined to
release an album the singer was signed
by the Sony Columbia disrupter Records
in 2018 and she's been working around
the clock to deliver the upcoming single
talks about while the singer has
confirmed that she has not ten songs at
the moment her album has yet to be
released
Duff came clean about her album during
build series interview and here's what
she had to say so I'm really excited and
right after descendants three I have a
whole bunch of songs lined up we don't
know about you but we're super excited
to see what dove has in store for us
what she's doing now dove is unlike any
22 year old we've ever met she's jumped
from one production to the next and
doesn't seem to be pressing the brakes
anytime soon she's evolved before our
eyes and we couldn't be happier about
the woman she's become although dove
confirmed that she'd be leaving Disney
the actress still has her hands in the
cookie jar while she won't be showing
her face in a Disney production any time
soon she's been lending her voice to a
Disney cartoon series marvel rising
initiation is a mini TV series that
aired in 2018 and dove is the voice
actress behind characters ghosts spider
and Gwen Stacy on top of that dove is
set to star as cher on the off-broadway
play clueless and were super excited to
see the rendition of the character and
since the actress enjoys keeping her
plateful she's also landed the role of
ruby in agents of shield but if that
wasn't enough the young starlet recently
filmed a movie with big-time star
Jennifer Aniston dumpling is said to
come out in theaters on December 7th
2018 and this is what dove had to say
about the movie and her co-stars during
an interview with j14 magazine for now
it looks like dove has her hands full
with projects but you never know what
else the star is going to pick up she
wants to join the Riverdale and Sabrina
cast most Millennials were more than
happy to find out that the Archie comics
were going to come to life before their
eyes Riverdale is a super popular show
and it doesn't come as a surprise that
dove wants in on it the actress
explained that she's friends with the
cast and that she'd be willing to join
the production during an interview with
shine on media dove stated that there
were a lot of rumors about her joining
the Riverdale cast circulating around
here's what she had to say about the
matter I loved the character Sabrina
I was a huge fan of the original Archie
comics I was like all I read when I was
little from what it sounds like Dov
would be happy with a part in Netflix
chilling Adventures of Sabrina or
Riverdale and hopefully the productions
will choose to include her because let's
face it she would make the best witch
ever so do you guys think that dub
deserves a spot on either one of these
shows let us know which you'd prefer in
the comments below and that's it for our
video thanks for watching and see you
next time on the things
[Music]